s'est transformé en ville morte tout
commerce fermé après les affrontements
qui ont suivi l'arrestation d'Ovidio
Guzman un défi du fameux narcotrafiquant
el chapo en prison aux États-Unis
mais les nombreuses carcasses de
véhicules incendiés au total 280
témoignent de la férocité des combats la
police locale et la garde nationale
continue à patrouiller en ville et à
surveiller les intersections
[Applaudissements]
deux avions ont même été cibles de tir à
l'aéroport de koliacane un militaire et
un civil dont les passagers à bord se
sont mis à l'abri de la fusillade
les avions ont pu décoller ensuite sans
encombre
le secrétaire à la Défense Louis
chrétienne sous Sandoval qui avait
d'abord rapporté un mort et 28 blessés à
réviser son bilan par la suite à 29 donc
10 militaires et 19 criminels et 21
arrestations la cible de l'opération
était au vidéo nusman
[Musique]
la souris et le chef présumé de la
faction les mineurs affilié au cartel du
Pacifique ou si nommé cartel de Sinaloa
que dirigeait son père roaquin Guzman
loeira le fameux el chapo Guzman
condamné et emprisonné aux États-Unis
on voit ici au vidéo lors de son
arrestation en 2019 à kullia Cannes
selon les autorités américaines avec ces
trois frères il trafique de la cocaïne
de Colombie l'effetrine d'Argentine pour
produire de la méthamphétamine ils
auraient mis la main sur plusieurs
laboratoires clandestins qui produisent
entre 1300 et 2200 kg de méthamphétamine
par mois le cartel de Sinan serait le
principal responsable du trafic de fin
d'année vers les États-Unis
îles Canada
l'arrestation du fils du chapeau en 2019
avait provoqué une bataille rangée entre
les quelques 700 membres de son cartel
et les forces de l'ordre qui avaient
fait 14 morts pour éviter un plus grand
bain de sang au vidéo Gusman avait été
libéré par le président Andres manuel
Lopez Obrador il a réagi ainsi au début
des affrontements du 5 janvier
le gouvernement mexicain ni qu'il y ait
quelques liens que ce soit entre
l'arrestation du jeune en vidéo Guzman
et la visite lundi du président
américain Joe Biden au Mexique où se
rendre également le premier ministre
Justin Trudeau Jean-Michel le prince
raducanada Montréal